senator raphael warnock wants to debate  you you didn't debate during the  primaries where you walked away with 68  percent of the republican votes  why wouldn't you commit to a debate well  first of all senator warnock has nothing  else to talk about he don't want to talk  about the high gas prices you don't want  to talk about the high groceries i've  told him many times i'm ready to debate  him anytime in a day i just want to make  it for the fans not about a political  party or about some media and all he's  doing is talking i want to make it a  fair and equitable debate for you are  you worried about the moderator what  understand he's saying  he warnock doesn't have anything to talk  about  and i'm willing to debate if it's for  the fans  that that's not an answer  that that should immediately make us say  can he think because he's not saying  anything that makes sense